winter is coming and there's no more
secrets game of thrones season five
season overview which means this is your
official spoiler warning i've been doing
spoiler-free on my episode by episodes
that's out the window i'm talking the
whole thing now i'm not entirely sure
where I'm gonna start on this and I'm
probably gonna be jumping around a
little bit all over the place but I will
say one thing that I'm not gonna talk
about it i'm not going to talk about the
ramsey sand so wedding because i did a
whole video about that just so i would
not have to talk about it here so if you
want to know what I thought about that
check that video out I suppose the one
ad on I will on that particular thing is
it did lead to some development and it
did I don't want to say it paid off very
heavily but it did develop into
something so it didn't feel like it was
for nothing the way that the Jamie
Searcy thing in season four was that
said I still stand by what I say there
and I think that the way that it was
depicted was still gratuitous and
unnecessary but moving on from that why
don't we start over across the Narrow
Sea and let's talk about everything that
went on there Denarius was really weird
for me this season I had a hard times of
wrapping my head around her I don't know
if they've been trying to make her more
enigmatic but I'm just having a harder
time getting a read on her and what
she's doing and why she's doing it the
only thing that I can come up with it
kind of makes sense to me is that as her
advisers were getting picked off or she
had banished them or whatever she just
seemed to lose her grass as far as what
was she was supposed to be doing I think
we got a we got a sense that her
advisors were a big part of why she was
so successful I mean she had yo her firm
moral she had her dragons she had her on
Sully but though she had some pretty
firm guiding hands as well and once
those were gone she really kind of
floundered both as a leader and a bit as
a character which is why finally getting
Tyrion showing up there really felt good
and I love the first scene with the two
of them just sitting down and talking
that is an amazing scene and i love it i
also really like where we leave Therrien
which is where I'd
like Tim best witches in control
basically I mean they make it very clear
they're basically gonna be calling upon
him to do in murine what he did at
King's Landing when he was the hand of
the king and he was awesome doing that
so I that makes me really excited for
what's gonna happen with him next season
now that said getting them getting him
there up until he finally sat down with
Daenerys t-raines whole story really boy
that one and what I talked about
spinning wheels that was something I
that was really kind of at the forefront
of my mind because think about it here
he's on his way to marine with Varys to
find an heiress and he gets kidnapped by
Sir Jorah who's gonna take him to
Daenerys ok and and then they get
captured by these slavers and convince
the slavers to take them to marine where
Daenerys is he was going someplace got
kidnapped by someone who's still gonna
take him there and then the two of them
got kidnapped by a group that was still
gonna take him to the same place he was
just going that's really unnecessary I
mean I know it got sir Jorah back into
the mix and i do like him although the
whole thing with the stone men and the
grayscale I'm not loving cuz first of
all I just seemed really weird for how
knowledgeable he seemed to be about this
whole part of the world the fact that he
even put them in a situation where they
were gonna be near these guys just
strikes me as out of character in the
first place and for no reason other than
just to get him infected so that he now
becomes a ticking clock and that was the
sort of thing when I mentioned in one of
my reviews just that's show really going
out of its way to bend around and do
things that didn't really make sense
just so we could have certain elements
like a character who was now infected
with gray scale I mean the show went way
out of its way so that that could happen
and I mean we'll see how it pays off
eventually but I I don't know if it's
gonna be work with what we went through
there were other things that threw me
off about De Niro storyline aside from
just her herself you know the whole sons
of the harpy thing there's a couple
things that I don't like about the way
that was handled the first is how often
they just seem to take apart the
unsullied and I
I do blame the execution on that I don't
think that unsullied are invincible or
anything but we've seen them be good
enough and they certainly were pumped up
is good enough that I'll believe that
they get overrun with sheer numbers but
it the way that the action season that
they're shot and all that it it rarely
looked like our felt like they were
being overwhelmed with numbers it just
felt like they were getting their butts
kicked and is it just me or in the
fighting pit were they just
indiscriminately killing people in the
crowd which also makes absolutely no
sense because if they're just trying to
give it a dinero's why are they killing
people who are I mean maybe they were
targeting freed slaves but if that's
what they were doing it was not made
clear the fact that there was a
rebellion in the City Marine cool I'm
down with that cuz again it shows more
of De Niro sort of realizing the
realities of being a conqueror and then
trying to rule but at the execution of
it I didn't love and kind of on the same
note the sparrows in King's Landing now
I said it before and I will say it again
and stand by the high Sparrow jonathan
pryce love him he's fantastic he's
perfect in this role I love the feel of
the character i love how different he is
from everybody else i'd love how much he
throws everybody off their game because
he is so sincere about what he's doing
he's not playing a game he's not doing
the political sparring that everyone's
used to I like him the sparrows as a
group I don't like just because part of
it has to do with how quickly things
turned around I don't love the fact that
it was like one minute they're all
there's this sort of little religious
thing that's going on the next thing
they're like the Spanish Inquisition but
you're supposed brings me to searcy and
what happens to her in the last episode
which I'm honestly not entirely sure
what I think about that what I will say
is what it did do that I like is that
it's now given C or C a reason to be the
cold-hearted [ __ ] we know she's so good
at being because at the very end when
reanimated Gregor picture up in the look
on her face is like I'm gonna destroy
them and she's always had that thing
I'm going to destroy them but in as part
of why I haven't I've never really been
completely on board with seriously as a
character for a lot of her use in this
series because she's just so petty I
mean she's in power she's in control she
just squishing people cuz they annoy her
a little bit but now she's got a reason
I mean she's got good justification to
want to tear people apart now and I kind
of like that better over in Dorne that
was another sort of it felt like
spinning wheels that went nowhere kind
of thing the sand snakes just felt like
nothing now I love the scene that
happens in the jail between Braun and
the 1i I'm sorry I don't remember her
name but I love that scene I love his
singing I love their interaction but I
don't feel that scene alone is enough to
justify the inclusion of the sand snakes
cuz you know they're got their fight
scene with Jamie and Braun was such a
mess that was the one I complained about
because I couldn't tell what was going
on cuz we got the three sand snakes who
looked the same fighting Braun and Jamie
who are dressed the same so I hated that
I hate it how quickly the sands thanks
got caught and the woman who was leading
them sort of got busted I guess she you
know she got her revenge on Marcello
which it was sad given what happened you
know Jamie had his moment with her which
was a sweet moment and then she kills
over pretty much immediately so I think
it plays out well I just don't we not
assured had a much of an impact on me
aside from just oh that's kind of sad
but again it feels overly wheel spinning
because now it's like well does that
sort of take Dorne out of this whole
thing as a player because now that woman
has gotten the revenge she wanted and
the San snakes were just sort of in it
with her so they won yay I don't know
it's like the first story line I can
think of for the show there's like that
then seems a little bit too easy since I
mentioned dorm we're talking about
islands let's talk Braavos I am liking
our historian I'm liking words going and
I like it sort of where it ends up in
the last episode that she she gets her
first bit of really personally getting
revenge as she's been trying to get for
a while and then we kind of be punished
for it it bonded me out a little to sort
of see that happening it was like
boy so that's the only bit of personal
revenge she's gonna get to get in this
show because now she's really gotta do
what she's supposed to do in this place
and I don't know if that blindness is
gonna stick or not but I'm really
curious to see what will happen well
they're definitely it was a while
getting there the hers was another story
that felt a little bit wheel spinning
because I I get that she had to go
through you know a while and it had to
take time and she couldn't just
instantly be learning their tricks and
but you know watching or just sweep the
temple and sweep the temple and clean a
body clean a body they just had her
doing the same things over and over and
over him for at least one too many
episodes let's work our way north a
little bit let's get to Winterfell which
brings us to the Bolton's Sansa Ramsay
did that I do really like what happened
in the season finale with Sansa and
Theon I'm a little bit annoyed that
Theon couldn't have had that moment
against Ramsay himself although I guess
you know baby steps he wouldn't have
been able to do it if Ramsay was there
but I smiled real big when he threw that
chick over the ledge because since she
was obviously really attracted to Ramsey
and she seemed like kind of cut from the
same cloth it was a little bit by proxy
felt a little bit like he was taking
down a part of Ramsey and that kind of
felt good I'll be interested to see what
picks up with them I mean they jumped
off a wall but they jumped off wall into
what I'm assuming was freshly fallen
snow so I'm not presuming death on them
since we're up in this neck of the woods
let's talk Stannis I'm really glad he's
dead and what's more I like the way he
died because second glass up so would he
killed Shireen that instantly made me
hate him I wanted him to die I wanted
him to die more than Ramsey I want him
to die more than Joffrey Joffrey as far
as we can tell was just born wrong he's
just inherently evil wicked little prick
Stannis has a conscience has a moral
Center he has these things that so far
as we can tell Joffrey just never had so
when he chooses to override those and
ignore those and
nor his paternal instincts as a father
and have that woman burn his daughter
and listen to her scream scream for him
and not do anything oh I am so glad that
not only did he die but his prayers went
unanswered just like his daughter
screams for him to save her went
unanswered just his realization that
this is not gonna happen the way he
wanted it to happen that what he did got
him nothing good glad he's dead the fact
that Brienne of Tarth was the one who
got to kill him was not as rewarding for
me as it was probably meant to feel but
if someone's gonna take him out I much
prefer her to do it then Ramsay or one
of the Bolton's because that was one of
the other things I said they by making
me hate Stannis it made me not really
care about the Stannis vs Ramsay
conflict and that fight but thankfully
they kind of dealt with that pretty
quickly up at the wall and north of the
wall well first we had hard home wow
what an episode that was that would
still my favorite episode of the season
even though I I did really like the
season valley boy that episode was
killer I love the action I love the way
that it was paced with you know they
start getting attacked by the whites and
then it's like well maybe they'll be
okay but then there's just this wave of
them and there's jumping off a cliff and
just splatter on the ground nothing just
jump up and keep fighting and that fight
also did a much better job of making the
Giants look badass than the assault on
the wall did last season if I'm being
honest and John John you know it was
probably about two years ago I said how
I didn't like Jon Snow and I was bored
with him and I found him on interesting
you know what since that happened he did
grow on me I did like him and I was
sorry to see him go unfortunately as
with so many things in this show it did
get spoiled for me not outright nobody
just came out and told me but just
things that I caught snippets from
things people said online yeah if you're
talking online and you're talking about
suppose I've don't be trying to be
cryptic and clever and like vaguely hint
at it you know what people pay attention
they figure it out and it's still a
spoiler whether your cryptic about her
whether you come and say it outright I
think the way that John was killed was
kind of fit I me was it was very it was
very Julius Caesar and then complete
with a Brutus in the form of ollie so
while I don't particularly like that
John is gone I think the way that it was
done was pretty good it was I think the
right note to end the episode as a whole
lon unfortunately i don't know how
invested i'm gonna be and what goes on
at the wall anymore because Sam left
John's dead Davros is up there but he's
not part of the Nights Watch I mean I
suppose if he finds out that Stannis has
been killed he might just stay there but
I I don't have a lot of investment in
the folks who are still up there which
makes the wall a little bit of an odd
place I don't know who are hook into
caring about what's going on there is
gonna be for this season that that story
ended fine I just I don't know where
it's gonna pick up and how that's gonna
play out and be interesting now what
else is there to talk about well yeah I
didn't talk about the dragon so I guess
I'll come full circle come back to
Daenerys I when the dragon showed up in
the pits I'd well I kind of saw it
coming that one I didn't have swell for
me I'm just watching the scene going
like all right either everyone's about
to die or dragons about to show I
thought that was a very cool scene I
like how he showed up I like how the
fight panned out that it showed you know
these dragons are not invincible you get
enough people who are not just gonna run
away from it to take it on and yeah they
could probably have taken him down if he
hadn't flown off but then where things
ended up on on the last episode with
donairs just with the Dothraki showing
up I don't know what to make of that
because I don't really know where she
stands with them I mean yes she was the
Khaleesi but because the cow she was
married to die that doesn't mean
anything I mean are they pissed it or do
they consider that she abandoned them do
they does this particular clan of
Dothraki even know who she is I mean all
they did was have a ton of Dothraki show
up but unfortunately it's been so long
since we've seen them I don't know what
that means I don't know where they stand
in all this so that was just an
note and her particular story for the
season so I guess that about wraps
things up for me for this season by the
end I I was feeling much better about it
the the first half of the season that
even past the halfway mark boy things
were rough I said it in my review of the
season value this this does stand as my
least favorite season it got better at
the end I mean episode eight was
phenomenal episode nine was kind of
rough for me to watch because of what
happened to Shireen but then the fact
that they didn't make me wait forever
the very next episode they give status
exactly what I wanted to have him happen
that makes this let these last three
episodes probably the strongest set of
closing episodes that the show has ever
had but the first half of the season and
and you know plus some of the little
lingering things that have gone on even
since then just ate away at the impact a
little bit when I look at the season as
a whole but that said there's some stuff
I'm really excited about for next season
I'm really excited for Tyrion just being
command again I really want to see what
Searcy's next move is gonna be I want to
see what happens to arion x Noah Brienne
of Tarth is gonna do now that she's
taking care of Santa's which is you know
one thing she really wanted to do but
she kind of unknowingly a banded Sansa
to do it what's gonna go on with that
and what's gonna happen exit what says I
actually care what's gonna happen with
Sansa whoa who would have called that so
I'm not gonna rank / seasons or but this
is my least favorite season overall
season four is my favorite season what
are your favorite and least favorite
seasons of this show so far out of the
five we've gotten whatever they are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned